golden temples beautiful beaches
bustling night markets Thailand has long
been a world-famous tourist destination
it's expecting a record number of 40
million visitors in 2019 well over half
the country's population and it's
dependent on tourist dollars it accounts
for about 20 percent of GDP but the
industry barely existed before 1960 its
origins were in fact born out of a dark
passage of American history here's how
war made Thailand a tourist destination
[Music]
the Vietnam War saw over 3 million
American soldiers sent to Southeast Asia
many would be stationed in Thailand
which became a major ally in the region
and home to seven US air bases at the
height of the conflict some 50,000
military personnel was stationed
throughout Thailand as America's
involvement in Vietnam deepened more
resources were pumped into the support
network in Thailand
as well as building highways and ports
the u.s. sent aid for other
infrastructure and social projects
aiming to improve living standards and
combat the spread of communism
all the while Thailand's capital Bangkok
became a center for air travel as
international airlines founded a
convenient location to refuel it was
here in Bangkok where many American
soldiers headed for rest and
recuperation for R&R days thousands of
colored neon signs proclaimed the city's
bars bath houses massage parlors and
dozens of luxurious nightclubs each with
its pretty Thai hostesses the notorious
red-light districts were hard to resist
for soldiers who'd spent months and
during the terror of the jungle
[Music]
the US soldiers were also big spenders
handing over almost 11 million dollars
in 1967 that's around 22 percent of
total expenditure by foreign visitors
and as the number of soldiers and other
visitors began to rise tourism
infrastructure increased to plush
air-conditioned hotels abound and new
shoe box style office buildings dominate
the skyline in the helter-skelter
transformation of what was once a sedate
oriental port
if the war ended in 1975 the number of
tourists dropped but only briefly the
industry will go from strength to
strength in the following decades the
infrastructure built for US soldiers and
businesses had a cost of over 1.6
billion dollars in military and aids
spending created the foundation for
today's Thai tourism industry in 2018
Thailand is expected to make 63 billion
dollars from tourism but Americans are
no longer the big spenders anymore
another superpower has taken that title
the Chinese
[Music]
you